what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here to watch division season
two episode seven eight and nine today joined
by MJ Tesla follow us Star Wars expert on
that social media use the force to leave a
like full-length Direction watch your luxury
sink up with your own coffee I'm sorry rejects
on a patreon page I think you all have joined
just for this show alone but of course these
episodes are sponsored by one of the greatest
sponsors we've ever worked with I don't mean
that in any hyperbolic sense whatsoever move
out of the way back take you again to me honest
for sponsoring this video guys I'm in a onesie
I've never owned a onesie and my epidermis
has never felt more comfortable nay I need
a better word than comfortable I feel as snug
as a bug in a rug I obviously love their clothing
I went to the Guardians of the Galaxy vol
3 premiere and I even wore the Rocket Raccoon
lounge pants and people would not stop talking
about it easily the most comfortable one there
at the event now I am venturing further into
the galaxy far far away you might say with
this limited edition print of grogu AKA baby
Yoda is the child himself grogu has traveled
across the Galaxy and into our hearts and
now you can meditate with him and galactically
soft undies socks bralettes loungewear and
more available in sizes extra small to 4XL
like I said the new Star Wars Prince is limited
so grab this bounty now before it's all gone
they also gave me their shorts which again
is so soft and perfect fitting too even my
wife loves to wear them speaking of my wife
I even got this bralette for her too I said
take it off I'm showing it in the video woman
she loves seeing me in this underwear my Jedi
Mind Tricks to keep her attracted to me don't
work but this underwear is doing the job wearing
it right now I've never been more relaxed
on camera sitting has just generally never
felt so soothing but yes rejection the hype
is real you're not impressed with me on these
your first pair is on the house Seth is a
promise so to get 25 off your first order
and free standard shipping go to mianis.com
rejects once again that is mionys.com Rejects
and May the force be with you always I hope
they partner up with us again because yes
[Music]
I like this already trained [Music]
oh this looks good Rings feel good what do
they even want charuk
that's the partition trade we are approaching
the Insurgent hideouts very treacherous
some major Clone Wars Vibes in this animation
Style
not now Ronnie but he gave it to me he said
no no again they're from the trolley
the best rightful
default until I'm back
I'm like 90 certain that I know that Jedi
exciting
what are you doing that way I saw it myself
[Music]
thank you
dumbass Stormtroopers
oh cause she wanted to play a flute
we saw what you did I love the theme of little
girls making stupid ass mistakes are here
[Music] nice eyes oh what's up oh awesome
[Music]
that's a great shot
damn this is cool oh no so fun
[Music]
oh ow right to the face
you're almost there
all the trouble you caused you want to just
complain that's our destination
[Music]
I love how they can Infuse other cultures
into this he threw a loaf at me don't listen
to him final warning you maggots wow storm
is approaching table number six
these are the literal Dark Times
um that girl just levitated the platter did
we miss something stop using the force little
girl that feels like a no-brainer right [Music]
uh please be an Inquisitor of some kind I
feel like that'd be super neat uh that is
awesome she hungry so her stomach just starts
making some sounds
a girl they saw in the train with unusual
balls I don't suppose you know any such girl
with unusual powers that old man to the right
I went to these Farm Villages just beyond
the train tracks and burnt them all no survivors
nothing
maybe you're right there you are
it's totally here you're right foreign [Music]
maybe that's why the Clone Wars animation
was purposeful
whoa
oh this is great
damn like entering the speed of force his
lightsabers and his Cane too
cool Inquisitor leave them alone
this is her
ah that was her fantastic you're dying
all right not what I was expecting but I'm
super here for it
oh this is great it's like a PS5
10 out of 10 old lady Jedis or what's up
yeah this was like a cinematic cutscene
that is the proper use of that lightsaber
damn [Music]
oh [__] a Jedi
[Music] God it doesn't look like a cinematic
cutscene like a game that looks amazing quickly
now
Moses ah they're probably gonna end up on
a hidden path I always knew you were meant
for bigger things
it's time you take that path now oh that's
sad this part is only meant for you there
are others like you here no one ever takes
enough of an empathetic approach when they
have to say goodbye to their family sorry
you can't go the bandits right for feast
oh mm-hmm
flute yeah oh May the force be with you
that's amazing
[Music]
that was amazing I really like that one a
lot man that was a 10 out of 10 for me I think
it's really cool this is coming out when so
much of this season of vision seems to at
the first season felt so much more like mainly
anime yeah or or like different types of riffs
within that side of the world this is so much
more worldwide yeah I mean it's a flavor of
of everything kinds of cultures Global animation
world has to offer the forces with everyone
and and I think it's cool too because I feel
like a lot of these Studios don't always get
to do what they're best at yeah because of
like market demand like this I want to make
a petition make that Cannon yeah like I want
to know more I want to continue to follow
that Adventure I would watch so much of that
I can only like imagine for for somebody from
like India how meaningful and special something
like this was see like some of my favorite
elements from Indian filmmaking Traverse into
the Star Wars Universe yeah stuff like this
is always really sweet because you're watching
it and like clearly there's some really really
big fans here obviously you're big fans of
the Clone Wars and took so many wonderful
elements part of me wonders if like some of
the model assets that they used throughout
it might even be from clone wars and then
just reimagined in terms of like the final
art style because it's just like slight little
tweaks that you you notice from it what a
strong strong episode yeah well I think it's
really cool to be doing this especially because
a lot of parts of the world have experienced
you know Wars as well um like real life historical
Wars and you know a lot of Star Wars often
it's only America and Germany obviously but
no I think a lot of you know Star Wars that
has been like mainly a riff on you know like
World War II where here you you see these
other parts of the world that are also uh
that can identify with it in terms of its
oppression and trying to find Hope and having
their underground systems where they were
able to build a rebellion or you know find
these kinds of individuals I thought was excellent
you know like I think there was like a lot
of like fun Peril that this episode had with
some gorgeous animation but that right at
the end was breathtakingly like PS5 high quality
Graphics to me in that way I'm like yeah this
is like the kind of cutscenes you look up
and you keep watching yeah and it was just
such a surprise like you would never suspect
the old lady yes it tricked it tricked and
I bet that was purposeful of course of course
they wanted to throw off the well it's funny
because the character that I thought I literally
said right before like oh yeah his lightsaber
is in a cane and they had his species in the
background which I thought was like such a
might have been intentional to throw it off
yeah to make it about a brother and sister
and a brother trying to like kind of that
last of us kind of style of like I gotta take
my brother and sister but is my little girl
at the same time yeah I'm taking them across
because there's someone special and important
and they have to let them go classic man DeLorean
even does it you know yeah this is like very
classic Star Wars but with Indian influence
right yeah I I thought even like the use of
the train uh was a great like like solo like
well at like in Indian culture like the use
of trains Community like it's it's a there's
a lot of layers uh and I just I don't know
there's so many beautiful cultural touches
yeah while we're exploring the Galaxy I feel
like it's a friendly reminder that like our
world is in so many ways just as big and just
as exciting alrighty guys that was an amazing
one another great one knocked out you ready
to watch next one no well let's do it anyway
you have no choice super sexy rejects we are
here to watch the next episode of Star Wars
Visions we're gonna watch episode 8 right
now just two more to go is this the one where
Luke drinks the milk yeah not the blue one
the straight out of the Ralph's grocery store
did you ever figure out what material the
meanders is made from the skin of God the
skin of God
please be tattooing please
oh this is striking
I love space capes
I love holes
[Music]
I think they're digging for
what are they digging for oh he's a fighter
[Music]
holocron lightsaber wreckage of a ship
[Music] kind of crystals I think so guess
so I wonder if they're on Jetta should probably
reward them wow slave mining I love this time
lapse
it's like an app build your own kyber Crystal
slave camp
the bottom well done Commander
Kill Them All all right
drool ah wow I was born in the darkness this
is where pain comes from are they just trapped
there I hope we Flash oh boy you gotta become
like Ant-Man and quantumania and just climb
on top of each other
well this is cruel as hell yeah I appreciate
how unique this is I've plotted the best course
to climb when I get to the top I'll go there
to find help help I my voice stay here it's
just too dangerous you're a Negative Nancy
Grandpa he'll do the right thing if they follow
their light I don't see any other way out
have you seen Hamilton yeah that's the voice
of Lafayette you think so feels like it David
Diggs David Diggs good job everyone has an
inner light no matter how dark it's always
there to guide you the right way don't be
afraid to use your voice and remind them to
follow the light
I hope you're right Michael or else I'm gonna
be coming at you saying not all black people
sound the same you don't know if the voice
actor is black Greg oh [__] you got me
he's climbing out awesome defeat Diggs is
Jewish so I feel like I get a pass
what I'd give to have arms like that
oh the humanity
oh he's gonna make little hand tools
oh hell yeah hell yeah a little bug
armadillo where are you
he's gonna tell them I'll go screw themselves
you might become a cage fighter
ah wait is this the city where Jack Black
and lizard Queen
look at this richly diverse Community excuse
me
this is really sad it's like living in New
York City oh true or L.A
flight you found the light follow it follow
the light cray there is a giant pit hundreds
of us are trapped down there deep below the
surface even children children we helped build
this city and now we need your help if you
follow me I can show you oh my God I hope
this has a bleak ass ending I would love for
her to be oblique you there hold it
One Jump Ahead of the [Music]
yep
poor guy just climbed a mountain
but I can throw him back in the pit let's
get Blake
that is a haunting illustration I don't think
is gonna wow
[Music]
oh he's straight up dead
wow [__] it's such hopelessness
[Music] They're Gonna Shine a Light they need
to know we're here
Crystal
follow the light follow the light follow the
light
that's cool
[Music] oh that's really sad
oh
no no no no no no they're coming back
I kind of would like it if they didn't I know
just go in really dark
see rich people are good rich people are good
rich people are good just follow the line
really nice that Elon Musk lended all those
ships for them blue check mark
it's only seven dollars
[Music]
[Music] hell yeah nice
you're a wizard Harry
I don't get it wow that was heartbreaking
that was a heartbreaking one despite all the
jokes you specifically kept making no that
was really heartbreaking
would have been nicer and in a really dark
place no I'm glad what the hell are rich people
gonna do huh yeah they would actually they
didn't even walk out there they're gonna offer
you refuge in the city that you built everybody
like bring a camera let's yeah let's monetize
this if I can uh get get some publicity on
this this will help me out yeah hey guys I
just found these people down in a hole and
we're gonna we're gonna help them out today
uh like And subscribe comment below Mr Beast
here to tell you you get eight thousand dollars
if you get one of these people out of the
hole that's my philanthropy work uh last cat
of the hole he gets nothing oh well so sad
too bad boom eight minutes clocking in videos
that was really sad just um I mean the divide
and this one spoke to classism no no no no
classism that's a big word woke uh sorry Society
no I I agree what happens when you film Eight
Episodes back to back when your conversations
take you I for one didn't see any socioeconomic
underlying message that they were trying to
convey in this piece what I saw is a bunch
of people dig a hole Craig and I don't really
understand why and then they bitched afterwards
yeah you have a new home they built you a
new town Yeah by far you forgot to bring rations
with you to survive you literally have shovels
yeah you could start again you could eat the
dead people it's true it's an endless so long
as you keep having children yeah there's an
endless endless supply oh it's we're not going
there that's a dark dark place but I do appreciate
tonally that this wasn't afraid to go a little
bit darker but it sounds like you and I want
even more the most realistic representation
from the what Society is really like in the
situation I feel like the best realistic representation
of what societies like in real life in Star
Wars is Anakin mowing down younglings yeah
um true true Amen to that brother watch that
I watch the whole expanded version of them
did you watch they don't they don't have one
where you watch the children did you watch
a fan film of I would make that fan film I'm
90 minutes long use like that's enough to
get away with being a feature do you want
to figure out if it was yeah please I hope
it's totally not uh you nailed it you nailed
it oh Steve Blum was the commander oh that's
so for those that don't know he plays Greg's
favorite Star Wars character yeah Zebula [Laughter]
and for this to be anime he also plays the
Cowboy Bebop himself yeah it's not Shrek uh
spikes you're right man it was defeated I'd
never get that right that is crazy and I've
I've restored a lot of faith and confidence
in myself ever said since I missed a med best
he should have wrapped his way and you gotta
motivated the people honestly wait for it
have you seen blind spotting no the the he
wrote them co-wrote that movie yeah he's amazing
in it have you seen a the new uh We're not
gonna do this we're gonna be here forever
but yeah I know this this was great at the
end of the day like the message of Hope in
the people is is also a nice thought yeah
now I'm thinking about this had Hamilton written
yes I'm too cynical yeah
if I would have shot them down yeah right
oh I just throw them out of cocktail yeah
I call it a day it was heartbreaking when
the guy is sacked I mean he died for a good
cause though they also like imagine waking
up to being like like pool party thrown into
the uh what an awful way to go and that's
like a long drop what do you think he thought
about um no I should have not done this [__]
should have not followed the light
all right last last one right let's do it
wow man this season flew by
yes Nate episodes
instances give me Lord more and more and more
okay good for the korbas so interested to
see this animation Style
it could be funny
that's gonna be funny I don't think so I think
it'll be cute wow look at that shot wow the
dimensions
can you smell it Greg
don't jump
it's her song is this the plot of Frozen two
[Music] oh this feels meditative
she must be checking in with Port security
she'll be here soon interlock have that same
kettle
sounds yummy remember to keep your distance
out
Jedi perhaps it's very unstable very dangerous
wow [Music]
whoa what the hell wild sometimes she has
more curiosity than since oh
oh dumb little girls all over Vision season
two you've grown and so curious I love her
fashion
hmm I have some business in town but perhaps
I'll visit the mine later and see the new
deposit
cannot keep happening to use your voice near
the crystal is dangerous wow frightens me
to think what will happen when I'm not there
to protect you that's what I say about John
I want you to be to be totally a Jedi
don't do our happy town everything is great
and we never ever frown
[Music] beautiful hard to believe that Darkness
was ever here
look at that pseudo-mandalorian have a good
day at work out I'll see you this evening
remember don't talk don't ever talk we're
never gonna fix that don't talk
that is that like a pimple what are we oh
I want one [Music]
bad feeling about it so do I I got a bad feeling
about this
we've got a bath
[Music] ah yes safety first child jeez
it's amazing that Civilization has made it
with the stupidity of children oh yummy
wow this feels so tangible
this tunnel runs deep he's about to die Big
Time death because of the season coming biggest
he's gonna fall down an even bigger hole Evil
Dead I really love how they capture the essence
of a crystal look at this camera work
that's it oh she's gonna slide I played enough
video games
oh she has to hold her mouth and nose that
she's going down what's wrong what does she
have a thing her natural speaking voice is
singing I know how to put that together I
don't think I've been paying attention
oh you're so right [Laughter] we're gonna
slide again
are you sure
all right
There You Go activate them all oh it's not
a curse it's a thing of beauty she's gonna
transform them with her heart [Music] yeah
some visual storytelling our beautiful singing
voice is gonna restore the Purity to the crystals
[Music] beautiful [Music] [Applause] [Music]
[Applause] fire
what uh what's going on
bad feeling confirmed
let's go dark told you bigger hole oh
puppy oh [Music] [Applause] [Music]
oh hell yeah somebody's been playing Jedi
Survivor
[Music]
not dark enough it's okay Abby
that wasn't singing you're right I didn't
even think about that [Music]
she's like a siren
damn this [__] is stunning
[Music] Still A better ending than razza Skywalker
speak now my child
she purified the Kaiba
how you had it all wrong you dumbass I can
help you nurture it but you would have to
come with me oh here we go consider it I'll
be leaving in a fortnight
she was later slaughtered by Anakin Skywalker
when she was a young lady
I am she needs to be nurtured I feel like
she's pretty good on her own yeah she just
sang a mountain into peace I'm proud
see Abby oh that is so touching
you're my favorite dumb little girl the show
has so far [Music]
but why
finally something quiet she wasn't dumb she
was smarter than the dad [Music] the Empire's
gonna attack now and that's how they built
Starkiller base
[Laughter] oh yeah oh man that was lovely
yeah it was beautiful I mean I I I wish they
would have gone a little deeper with it but
what do you mean well I feel like we in the
very beginning we had that that might even
been the first episode that beautiful piece
that used art as the painting episode yeah
it's communicate through the force and I thought
there was something really interesting about
the idea of communicating with music um but
like that's the best she got I I was expect
like I don't know like like lyrics I Wanna
lyrics
I wanna I wanna hear your struggle and song
sister I don't know that was just uh no it
was fine I got some major Frozen two vibes
from it
can't ever be happy Star Wars fans dude I
literally understand nothing but positive
it was beautiful it was fun the animation
looked delicious I would have even any one
of those said pieces last time I like felt
that hungry watching something was like during
Willy Wonka where I was like I want to take
a bite of that it's like a lollipop tree anyway
what'd you think Greg um I thought it was
really sweet I mean it's one of those where
it's it's got this almost dreamlike tone to
it so it is about like I I don't know I'm
curious to know what it's like for you guys
when you binge Visions because you know on
our end do you binge Visions there are people
who do the first time I didn't have you I
just talked to myself it's awesome it's a
great idea Michael to talk to myself for a
while and review this by myself because it's
different in our in our setting you know where
you just like we got lights on and we talk
about it afterwards where you know as as opposed
to if you're just at home and you binge it
because to me this is the kind of episode
I'm like oh yeah I would have loved this uh
in a sense of just like sitting back and like
the the visual illustrations when she does
sing and connect to the kyber crystals um
where it does feel like she's getting in tune
with like this isolation of just her space
and the Kyra crystals I think is gorgeous
so there was a lot of there's a lot of beautiful
stuff to it and of all the ones that had the
claymation sense to it I thought this was
the best looking one um yeah I mean I really
feel like a world brought to life yeah I I
agree I think uh they could have it could
have had some rap uh
give me five minutes in a beat Greg uh no
I I think there was definitely if I was alone
watching this at my home in the darkness well
they don't ever come here again Michael like
then recovery like I feel like my serotonin
post this episode would have been really high
but instead here I find myself with glaring
lights in your company yeah feeling somehow
more depressed than when I started so no this
was I have to say season two visions um way
better than season one way better a lot I
think they learned a lot of lessons um and
I think part of that lesson being uh I got
this sense that there was a a bit more cohesion
between the the Stu like Lucas and and the
animation companies whereas I think last time
they just like come up with anything I think
this time there might have been like some
direction I'm super I would I would have liked
a little bit more variety on C like a lot
of these if I just watch like one so weak
you know and then I I don't but it does get
to when you binge it and you're like God damn
just a lot about like Ivory crystals well
it always leans back into that like the very
very spiritual essence of Star Wars which
I feel like which is great for laconic storytelling
yeah yeah but that being said yeah I was like
that's a big SAT Word uh but I I feel like
for this sort of thing like I really enjoyed
our episodes where they're I mean there's
only really one right where there wasn't much
use the fort too I suppose uh and those were
the two of the strongest episodes the French
Resistance piece and the Bane's origin story
of the dark hole from what she came from yeah
I mean but I I still I really there wasn't
as opposed to Vision season one I was like
I'm not gonna remember the [__] I don't
know but but there were some standout ones
and vision season one the one that were David
Harbor did the voice with the two Jedi and
the crazy old guy I loved the the very first
one they did that was like uh black and white
um that was excellent um but here the the
variety palette was a big Saving Grace and
and you do get the sense of unique voice for
each one even right down to this one um but
yeah I do think there should be some coordination
at least with hey you know we got a lot about
like light versus dark and uh it was just
like I know it's like traditional Star Wars
but it's like a bite-sized mediums when you're
starting a new story it's like this I think
that's an interesting note for The Animation
Studios yeah because I'm sure there is a degree
of freedom in the creative about some kind
of pitching process probably just got like
a time limit yeah I know that's exactly what
it time and budget limit yeah uh but I think
there is or probably just budget honestly
like you can make it as long as you can go
because the lanes did really vary from piece
to piece um they were mainly 15 minutes on
average but there was a few that were a little
bit longer there was one that was like eight
and nineteen that's one the one the one in
Japanese nine there was one that was long
that one in particular did not as much for
me as I wanted it to but uh it started off
like a wood but then it didn't yeah then it
landed pretty flat but all in all uh this
was just a a wonderful exercise and creative
storytelling I mean I feel like uh and for
those that are like aren't in the film world
uh this kind of felt like going to a film
festival uh only they were good yeah I've
been to some shitty film I'm telling you guys
just spill festivals sound way more excited
yeah as a winner of many I can confirm it's
a it's not necessarily the greatest barometer
of it's like wow if we won that's bad news
uh but uh no but it it had that kind of what
I imagine some of the more premium film festivals
feel like yeah um you know but all in all
I think uh uh I love the timing of this because
there is a slight pause in Star Wars content
until the end of summer and I feel like this
is a nice kind of hold this over well you
know while we wait because I want to see one
episode that really I want to see something
that really does explore the debate of when
they asked because it happened like several
times in the season of the child has to come
with me and then like the fade two this child's
coming I want one where it's just that just
the contemplation just the debate of like
like it starts off there and like really explain
the odd like like a play like I I feel like
you could achieve that and we might see something
like that in Tales of the Jedi which I feel
like is a really are they coming back yeah
they got confirmed for season two oh those
are great yeah no it was it was really strong
um and I like that like consequential wise
like it's just like ah Dave filoni wanted
to tell this story and we have all the character
models yeah true so um well reject Nation
I would love to know your thoughts Greg is
indifferent to your personal opinion care
less what you think about anything guys but
me on the other hand I religiously read the
comments and I always love uh reading what
people have to say especially about me oh
sweet well the day you guys turn on me I turned
that hurt into anger which is how you should
handle your hurt man all the men out there
in relationships well and you're hurt lash
out with rage
well you heard it here first folks uh rage
follow the darkness best way to do it cool
guys do it well uh we'll see you during the
show are we gonna tell them about what we're
gonna do together oh yeah we want to do the
holiday special yeah because you never finished
it I can't I've I said I can't but we're gonna
have to it's it's that'll be my first movie
review with you I've never oh yeah it would
be it's two hours it's a feature I know that
was the part that turned me off as I'm like
whatever little Clips I've seen of holiday
special I've been like I don't think I ever
want to watch this I feel like by the time
it's done I'll have pulled all of my teeth
out like I think we should take something
that's a hot take and um like G fuel
did I do it right
probably not all right reject Nation May the
force be with you and until the holiday special
good luck laughs [Music]